if that I would like to
right the first speaker it will be
skiff telling from ebert and the Cornell
Lab of Ornithology speaking about
informing bird conservation at multiple
spatial scales he'll be followed by Eric
matter who is the director of the video
of life very exciting global initiative
about bringing knowledge together about
species and finally her Odyssey bias
will talk about conservation at global
skills really excited about the the high
caliber set of speakers we've brought
together for the symposium and everybody
please join me in welcoming Steve
killing from Cornell thanks thanks
Walter
am i loud enough I think I'm too loud
should I keep talking until I that
sounds better the one thing I'd like to
add to what Walter said was not only are
a spatial scales important but what I'm
going to try to do today is is proved to
you that temporal scales are also and
being able to look both spatially and
temporally across a broad range of
different scales is what I want to focus
my talk on and the underlying hypothesis
of the work that I'm going to describe
to you is that if we can gather
sufficiently large quantities of data
with relatively low per datum
information so the kind of data that you
would get from a volunteer network
citizen scientists we can we believe we
can accurately then estimate species
distributions across broad spatial and
temporal scales
so in this in this talk what I'm going
to do is describe a volunteer network
that we've developed to gather these
observations I'm going to then briefly
explain our observational data model and
the cyber infrastructure that maintains
that because that's a key component of
making all this functional and then
finally I'll describe some basic
research and computer science statistics
and ecology which have led to measurable
conservation outcomes so for the past
200 years in the United States
volunteers have participated
significantly in ornithology and
beginning in the early 2000s the Cornell
Lab of Ornithology and National Audubon
Society developed a project called eBird
which is which was developed to take
advantage of newly emerging at the time
information technologies to engage bird
watchers to submit observations to a
central database
so the goal of Ebert is to allow anybody
to submit an observation of a bird
anywhere in the world and this graphic
is shows you one day of observations
submitted to e bird back in March 2011
now what we do with eBird is we've
created a checklist program so observers
don't send us information about single
birds but they send us information in
the form of a checklist where we require
certain pieces of information to allow
us to standardize the way people collect
those observations so for example we
collect the who what where how many how
long and what distance they may have
traveled as well as a a question about
whether they're reporting all the birds
that they've observed so based on that
as our our data model and and all of our
protocols set up like that over the past
nine years we've been able to gather
around seven million check lists and a
hundred million observations so who's
submitting all of these data well
depending on where you read there there
are tens to hundreds of millions of
people who are bird watchers globally
many of the more serious bird watchers
like to keep lists of birds and
checklists when they go out and that the
top of those even collect more
information very specific about birds
and and their officer and and keep
detailed notes about the observations
even they've made so we've taken
advantage of that with eBird and have
developed a website where they can
contribute their observations or more
recently you can see on the bottom your
bottom left we've developed in
partnerships with other groups
applications that allow us to
collect data directly from iPhones and
and other handheld devices so what we've
done with eBird is develop a community
of participants by providing that
community with all the features that
bird watchers or birders like to have
when when they participate in birding
one of the major things birders love are
lifeless and lists of birds so Ebert
allows them to keep life lists of their
their world lists or their favorite
country lists or state lists or County
lists or back yard lists or bathroom
lists there's there's all kinds of
different lists that birders like to
have and keep and maintain and we allow
them to do that all through all through
the application birders also like to see
their names and how their names rank and
their their observations ranked with it
with their friends and people in very
specific regions so so we we provide
various kinds of data visualizations
where they can see how they rank
compared to other people's ranks and
either the number of check lists they've
submitted for a region or number of
species they've observed and we also
allow them to play games and and this
yard list game is one in which it's a
it's a global competition where people
identify their backyards and then they
submit repeatedly observations from
their backyards and these kinds of
competitions then are really great for
us in the analysis of bird populations
because we get repeated sightings from
the same location by the same observer
so you can see that in Tompkins County
where Cornell is I'm the best
and I have a lot of competition I don't
know if you know you might recognize
some of the names of that the other
thing about e bird is that we create a
whole series of different data
visualizations real time data
visualizations to allow people to see
either through histograms like this or
maps or graphs patterns of bird
populations at a variety of different
scales and and bird watchers like these
histograms in particular because it
allows them to make decisions on what
birds they might see on a trip that
they're going to go to so for example
before I came to to Yale I looked at a
bird and noticed that there was a wood
Sandpiper which is a European vagrant
and Rhode Island so I found that through
e bird and after this conference I think
I'll go there and look at it more
importantly though these kinds of
seasonal patterns and occurrence are
used by land managers particularly
during migration to establish water
levels for waterfowl when they move
through and then lowering what are
levels when when shorebirds come through
now there's no question that we have
real issues with data quality
particularly in detectability and and
differences in the patterns in which and
which one observer can identify Birds
versus the other so what we've done to
try to deal with this issue is we've
recruited around 500 volunteers who have
a separate website that allows them to
vet and review the the data that that
people submit contact those observers
and roughly about 10% of the data that
we currently get gets flagged for review
and about half of
gets rejected currently we just received
funding from the National Science
Foundation to begin employing some new
machine learning tools to allow us to
begin to understand a observer expertise
better and use those in our models eBird
is based on a series of about 30
partners across global partners who who
coordinate activities in their states or
countries who've translated the ebert
application into Spanish French and
Portuguese and work with us to develop
techniques and functionality for the
site so the result is that eBird has
been experiencing exponential growth
since the start of the project in fact
one of the interesting little tidbits is
that during the month of May this past
year we collected more data and Niebuhr
than we did the first three years of the
project
but their holes and this is a map
showing all the locations globally where
where we have observations and it sort
of looks like a world map but you can
see like Brazil is is empty and Africa
needs work and Russia doesn't exist so
so while we've made we've made good
progress and collecting data globally
and we still need to do more work to
expand this but what really is exciting
to me personally is the fact that
because our the way that we collect
eBird checklist data people tell us how
long they're in the field we get an
estimate then of how much time they've
actually volunteered to participate in
the project this is to me a huge number
of ours so now I'm going to switch her a
little bit because in order to make all
of this kind of functionality run you
really need to develop and manage and
maintain the expense of a a data
management infrastructure that allows
you to to develop and produce tools and
functionality in the same time period
that what people expect over the
internet so we've developed a data model
that is a series of four relational
tables that that store all of our
information on the location who the
observer was the protocol information
during the collection event and then the
species observation itself and then from
that though that particular set of
tables we can relate them together to
quickly develop a series of data
warehouses and other kinds of
functionality to to provide access to
the data the other thing that we've done
is developed a more open architecture to
allow application development initially
we had just allowed in-house developers
to to create tools and functionality for
eBird but there was a request from the
community to for us to build api's
program or interfaces to our database to
allow people in the community to develop
applications and now we have hundreds of
different outcrops of applications that
show rare birds in a region or
applications that show trends that these
people have developed additionally we've
developed an API which we control more
which where we allow people to actually
input data into eBird and that's led to
the iPhone application several
applications like that
finally we're really committed to either
to make
this data openly available and recently
we we've switched our data data access
policy where we've asked individuals to
identify themselves and give us just a
brief abstract of what they plan to do
with the data currently we get about
three or four requests daily for the
data set this is just a list of
different organizations that made that
the request for uber data in August
okay so we've collected all this data
we've we manage it well so we know it's
not going to go away but the I still
really haven't asked the answer the
question can you really do anything with
this messy data from you know think
about the the our observers as a sensor
network a semi autonomous sensor network
where each sensor is different from any
other sensor in the network so it's an
engineering challenge in the way that we
we develop the processes in which we
analyze these data but I would argue
that we're fairly successful in the
kinds of data visualizations and species
distribution and occurrence maps that we
can generate for this for example this
is the map we call these heat maps on
the left is of the breeding breeding
distribution of wood thrushes in in the
eastern United States and up front I'm
going to apologize our analysis right
now are only going to focus on the
United States the lower 48 states not
because of the e bird data but because
of the environmental variables that we
selected early on to build our model
predictions our goal over the next year
is to do western hemispheric wide and
analyses so I'm sorry but you can see at
least for the United States that that
the the way that our models show
differences in relative abundance where
you know probabilities of detecting wood
thrush in and you know the major mining
regions of West Virginia and eastern
Ohio are where they're most abundant and
in the cornfield areas of you know Iowa
through through Ohio where these birds
used to be quite common they're not that
common anymore the other thing that's
exciting about of how we we've developed
these models is that we can model a
estimate a species distribution for any
time of year so so we can begin to see
the importance of time in biodiversity
and patterns of species occurrence
across broad spatial scales so this is
this has been a quandary for us it's
this multi scale species distribution
modeling challenge so you know our goal
ultimately is to to analyze species
distributions at hemisphere wide scales
but with fine enough spatial and
temporal resolution and where to allow a
land manager to make a decision or an
application in a very specific region so
we're using very fine scale variables at
but we're scaling these fine scale
burial variables up to to really large
regional and year-round processes so we
do these runs annually
you'll we run these models annually and
you'll see in the next slide why but in
our fourth run of the Ebert analyses
these were the number
locations across the United States it
was about 500,000 locations where we had
collected observations of birds that
were used in the models so what we do is
we take the e bird data and that
location and time information and we
link that data with land cover variables
fragment statistics that allow us to
look at patches and fragments of land
cover types in the environment we use
human population data a meteorology data
and in the and in the past we've used
NASA modus Landsat imagery to begin to
look at and model these species
distributions using a new modeling
regime that we call the spatial temporal
exploratory models so these models
though are very very data-intensive such
that for us to to run the models that we
just did on 200 species required us to
use two and a half million hours of
processor time so we didn't do that with
using one processor we we could paralyze
the process and actually ended up using
the National Science Foundation's exceed
high-performance computing Center in the
University of Texas to use five thousand
processors simultaneously to run these
analyses and the output was predictions
of patterns of species occurrence at the
three kilometer grid scale across the
entire continent so what's exciting now
and then to hit home again on the
temporal part is that we can see the
patterns weekly patterns and species
occurrence across the United States
it's during the entire year that the the
bird is in the United States so for this
particular species the end or go Bunning
there's a small population that winners
in South Florida but most of these birds
winter in Central America they then move
across the Gulf of Mexico move quickly
up into their breeding areas avoiding
cities see the black hole where Atlanta
is and the center of their population
remains then beginning in August they
move back down across the Gulf of Mexico
back to their winter patterns winter
distributions what's interesting though
about these kinds of data is it just not
only creates pretty pictures but we can
see that there's variability in habitat
usage of populate bird populations
during during the time that they're
there in the United States so for
example with with indigo bunting during
the breeding season and the core part of
its range so this area indigo Bunnings
are found primarily in in wooded areas
where they where they nest up in trees
and they eat insects and they're not
particularly found in pastures but but
in August the indigo bunting goes
through a molt and they begin to switch
over their behavior to the kinds of
behaviors that they they exhibit during
their winter season the non-breeding
season when they're in Central America
so they switch from for preferring a
deciduous forest and move into pasture
lands where they and they switch from
eating insects to eating seeds so these
kinds of population level analyses are
really exciting for us to be able to
pull out of this large data set we're
also able to see how different
subpopulations of the same species
change over time so for example this
this is a another animation of orchard
Oriole and where we think there are at
least two different subpopulations of
this
in the united states so again this is a
bird that that not only winners in
Central America but also in South
America it's a trans Gulf migrant also
so it appears initially and moves in the
Gulf and moves very rapidly up into the
along the East Coast then then they
arrive more gradually in the central
part of the country the East Coast birds
move back more quickly into and then
this the central birds become returned
so follow this when they hit the coast
now look how fast they move up into the
East and then several weeks later they
move into the central part then they
leave the East sooner delay and central
part and then then disappear so these
these kinds of patterns are allowing us
to begin to ask questions exploratory
questions about how the phonology of a
bird may may impact the genomics of the
bird and cause speciation in these these
different species a lot of this data has
been used by the Department of Interior
to do its annual state of the birds
report and the first time that that that
USGS and lab and Forest Service groups
did the analysis we looked at the
patterns of occurrence of species on on
public lands so for example we generated
a whole series of these pie charts where
we first estimated the proportion of a
population of a certain kind of group of
birds in this case arid land species in
the southwest and we found that the
about half of the populations of those
birds were found on public lands then we
can change that continue to look at that
and see that most of the those arid land
species are at
occurring on on Bureau of Land
Management lands so for the first time
we were able to show show these these
agencies these land managers which
populations of birds which particular
species are they most responsible for
what was most exciting to us was that we
were finding again because of the
temporal aspect of our analysis the
stewardship responsibilities change
seasonally so in both of these maps or
graphs you can see that during the
breeding season in the center part the
highest proportion of of both mountain
bluebirds or willow flycatchers during
the breeding season are found on u.s.
Forest Service lands but during the non
breeding season for mountain bluebirds
they they move down in elevation and
move farther south and and into Bureau
of Land Management lands so what what
these kinds of graphics are beginning to
show us and inform land managers is that
there needs to be more cooperation
between these public agencies and being
able to make sure that these birds are
managed properly the other area that
we're looking on is beginning to study
detail the details of migration and
analysis at the population level so we
really want to ask the question is can
these patterns and migration that we've
seen with the e bird stem model results
do they agree with theoretical
expectations developed by banding data
or radio telemetry data so what we did
was we gridded out all of the e bird
checklists in North America you can see
like some of these dark red grids have
as many as 50,000 checklists in them we
reduced that grid length to two area
where we we had a lot of
the most contiguous set of grids and
then for about a hundred species of
birds we estimated the center of the the
population as the bird migrates daily up
into the breeding season and then back
down so what you can think of is this is
a blob of birds moving back and forth
and we're plotting the centroid of those
and what you see are these these plots
where the blue line is the daily
migration of black-throated green
Warbler has moves up into its breeding
area and and our our population level
models show that they they move very
rapidly and then the red line shows them
coming back down at a much more slow
slow rate you can see that different
species like this black-throated blue
Warbler moves back and forth following
the same path where the black-throated
green follows a different path so the
really cool thing though we were able to
do working with the Nature Conservancy
in California was to look at species of
special concern particularly in the
along the Pacific Flyway and combine
these two kinds of models where we look
at the daily migration of birds and then
their patterns of occurrence so during
and this is for the long-billed curlew a
species of specific interest for Nature
Conservancy we can see that during the
winter period were in the non breeding
period there it's not a lot of movement
not much happens until about early March
and then you can see the birds moving
rapidly up into the breeding area in the
upper Plains they only stay there for a
couple of weeks and then they start
moving down again quite rapidly but
what's exciting
what we were able to find in this kind
of analysis light is that at the end of
July their migration stops so the
population quits moving and we were able
to identify real specific locations
these happen to be very arid areas in
Eastern California and Nevada and
Eastern Oregon near water where these
birds stopped migration and actually go
through a period of several weeks where
they molt the tnc was interested in this
because these were areas that weren't
under any kind of management regime
except for tule Lake which is a Wildlife
Refuge so we were able to show them some
new information by using the this this
kind of data then they returned so in
conclusion what I'd like to say say is
that engagement is is really the key and
if if we don't get enough data coming
into this system then our results are
not going to be very good regardless of
how sophisticated the models are
regardless of of how many processors we
use to do these kinds of analysis or how
cool the visualizations are if we don't
collect enough data our data our results
are not going to be very good the second
is that we you need to have sound data
management framework to not only take
care of these data and provide it back
for the users but also to maintain the
systems over long periods of time and
then finally we need to develop new
kinds of analysis techniques to process
this very noisy very unstructured data
and and and that's we've been able to
use a combination of parametric and
nonparametric techniques
so I always have to acknowledge our
funders for this work and particularly
acknowledge all of the thousands of
contributors to eBird and I can honestly
say that I didn't do any of this work
this group of people did so thank you
thanks a lot to you citizen science big
theta project out there and addressing
some really important
conservation and management and using
the basic required with the science only
have time for one quick question while
Eric is next Eric Martha I just could
already come up and start setting things
up but the model was built to predict
the patterns in 2011 so we combined data
to focus the model for making a
prediction on one year that's a the area
that we want to go to now and we're at
the point where we're collecting enough
data so that we'll be able to look at
trends from year to year annual trends
on migration patterns
well there are two things that we do the
first is that we've we make the data
available so I don't think that there
are many groups that could reproduce
what we did and in the kinds of analysis
but the other thing that we do do is all
of the modeling software is written in
our the our programming language and
that's published as a we try to extend
the community the last time we looked
there were probably 90 different
publications 90
most of them not from us